[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So I thought maybe
you could start by just giving
a quick intro to All Out.
For people who aren't familiar
with the organization,
tell us a little bit about it.
MATT BEARD: Yeah, sure.
So as, I think, many people
[INAUDIBLE] over 70 countries
in the world, it is
illegal to be gay.
And in 10 of those
countries, your government
can actually legally kill you,
just for being who you are.
So what All Out does is it
enables millions of people
around the world to take
action on LGBT rights,
and we do this with people power
combined with tech, strategy,
and research.
And we bring those
elements together
to enable millions of
voices to come together
to make a very, very loud
noise about LGBT rights,
to raise the volume, to
protect LGBT people when
they are at risk, and
to grasp opportunities
when they come for our
equality and our dignity
around the world.
SPEAKER: OK, great.
Awesome.
That's a pretty good intro.
So I guess we can dive into a
little of the specifics of work
All Out has been doing recently.
I did want to give a
warning to folks in the room
and on the Livestream.
Obviously, when we talk
about these issues globally,
there's a number
of sensitive topics
that can come up, including
violence and sexual assault,
and we're no stranger to those
issues in the west, either.
But if at any time folks
feel the need to step out
of the room, that's totally
fine, and no questions asked.
So let's talk a
little about pride.
There was some talk
in the room before we
started about protests and
the importance of protests.
And I know that one thing that
All Out does a lot of work
with globally is pride events,
pride festivals and protest
marches, and all that.
So can you talk us a little bit
about why that is so important,
particularly in our context,
where pride in San Francisco
is kind of a party
at this point.
It's lost some of that protest.
MATT BEARD: Sure, yeah.
So I mean, I think there's
an initial question,
as to whether pride in New York
or San Francisco or Chicago
or DC should only be a
protest, particularly
against the backdrop of the
current situation that we
find ourselves in.
But in many countries
around the world,
that isn't even up for debate.
Where it is illegal to be who
you are, taking part in pride
is a massive act of
defiance and courage.
And it is visibility that
really makes the difference.
If we think back to
the advances that we've
made in the United States,
Europe, Australia, Canada,
over the last 50 years, it is by
LGBT plus people being visible,
being out there,
that has actually
allowed us to make the
significant changes that we
have.
And so All Out, mainly through
our crowdfunding program,
which is called Grassroots
Giving, in which we
ask our global membership
to make small contributions
to fund frontline activism
or service delivery,
around the world.
Through that
program, we have been
able to fund a number of
prides around the world.
And we do that
because we believe
that those moments of
visibility, solidarity,
community, that those
groups can have,
through organizing
pride for themselves,
are enormous catalysts.
They're like a big battery
boosting those movements.
What we find, though, is
that after a successful pride
in a hostile
environment, it really
kind of catalyzes the
movement for the whole year
and enables them to
live a really, really
effective activism.
So we believe that what
happened in Stonewall in 1969
was a seminal moment, that
our ancestors have given us
something very, very
precious to work with,
to take that tradition and to
spread it around the world,
and to make sure that, as
LGBT people plus people,
we remain visible.
We remain physical
and on the streets,
and we claim our rights in
a very clear and open way.
SPEAKER: OK, and so you
said a successful pride
can have a lot of impact,
in terms of visibility.
What does that look like,
a successful pride event?
MATT BEARD: So a
successful pride event
in a hostile
environment, firstly, it
looks like an event
which is peaceful,
where LGBT plus people
have not been physically
attacked or intimidated.
It is an event where the
freedom of association
is guaranteed by the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights,
has been respected so
that people are allowed
to gather as LGBT plus people,
to be in one space at one time
together.
And it looks like
an event where there
has been a critical mass
of people coming together.
And a critical mass, in many
of the environments we work in,
can be as few as 50
people, really, who
can really make a difference.
When I worked at Amnesty
International, 10 years ago,
I took part in one of the
first prides in Riga in Latvia.
And there were
literally 50 of us
in that space and around
10,000 counter-protesters
trying to disrupt that event.
We were protected by the
police in a very efficient way,
and so it remains safe.
I went back 10 years later,
this summer, to Riga,
and those numbers
had, basically,
inverted, that there were
8,000 people participating
in pride and a very sad
looking group of Nazis who
were protesting against us,
probably around 50 or 60
of those.
So that, for me, to
answer your question,
shows the progress
that can be made.
From that courageous
moment 10 years ago
when those Latvian
activists decided
that they were going to
stand out and do this thing,
despite the risks,
despite the violence,
despite the intimidation,
and in 10 years
they've turned that
thing around completely.
And it was a joyful
occasion where, as I said,
8,000 people were
able to come together.
SPEAKER: Wow.
That's incredible.
Quite a flip.
OK, so let's talk about
some specific prides
that All Out has been
involved with recently,
and we can see if folks in the
room have questions as well.
So I know recently, you had,
in the same weekend, Swaziland
Pride and Istanbul Pride.
MATT BEARD: Yes.
SPEAKER: All Out was doing
work with both of them
simultaneously, and there's
pretty different outcomes
from both, from
what I understand.
So could you tell us
more of that story?
MATT BEARD: Yeah, I'll
tell you about both prides.
Very, very different stories
in both those places.
I'm going to start
with Swaziland Pride.
I have the privilege to be there
myself for Swaziland Pride.
This was also part of All Out's
global crowdfunding program.
So members from around 50
countries around the world,
including African
countries, all participate.
An average gift of
just $19 came together
to enable all of the security,
the logistics, everything
that was needed to run this
first ever pride in Swaziland.
For those who don't know,
Swaziland is a tiny country.
1.2 million people, just kind
of Northeast of South Africa.
It is the final absolute
monarchy in Africa
and it is illegal
to be gay there.
It is criminalized.
And so when our
partners from Swaziland
came to us over a year ago
with the incredibly kind
of audacious idea of
running pride in Swaziland,
we were super excited by it.
Because it's rare to have
pride in Africa, anywhere.
Uganda is one of
the few countries
that has managed, partially,
to pull off a pride event.
And that this tiny country
with an absolute monarchy,
with criminalized
homosexuality, that they
were going to take
this daring step,
we found incredibly exciting.
So we said, yes.
We will go out and we
will raise the money.
And we reached the target
through this global support.
It was a bumpy journey.
We initially got all of the
police permissions in place.
We had signed and
stamped documentation
that gave permission for this
public event to go ahead.
But unfortunately, in the few
weeks leading up to the event,
as is often the case in
Africa, the Christian right
mobilized significantly.
They were placing editorials.
They started a digital
petition through a platform
called CitizenGO, which is kind
of the opposite alternative
of All Out, if you like.
They use digital technology
and people power to campaign
against sexual and reproductive
rights and LGBTQ rights.
And they were able to
launch this petition, which
started to impact on the popular
discussion within Swaziland.
And that affected the police.
So three days before the
event was due to start,
the police just rescinded
all of the permissions
that they'd given,
which they can do
because it's not a democracy.
And we had to work
really, really hard
with diplomatic
channels, et cetera,
to bring that permission
back, which we did.
We did, with about
12 hours to spare.
SPEAKER: Wow.
MATT BEARD: And
during that time,
there was a very, very
difficult discussion
about whether we would march
anyway, with all of the risks
that that entailed.
We didn't come to
a final decision,
but the police permission
was put back in place.
Then we started to get
credible threats relayed
through our private security
company of a firebombing that
would take place
during the march.
And again a very, very difficult
decision, not made by All Out,
made by our partners.
We always make sure that they
have agency in these things.
But a very difficult decision
whether or not to go ahead,
but we decided we
would go ahead.
And so on a bright,
sunny Saturday morning--
it's winter there.
It was warmish.
In this field that you can
see on the slides right now--
it's a sports field--
around 300 LGBT plus
people gathered.
I need to really
emphasize with the guys
that this was not only
the first ever pride,
but according to
our partners, this
was literally the first time
that more than about seven
or eight LGBT people had ever
come together in one place
at one time in this country.
And you can see the
joy on the faces.
This is before we
even started marching.
It was incredibly moving,
even before we set off.
But once we set off to walk
probably 200 or 300 meters
through the city of Mbabane,
the capital of Swaziland,
I have to tell you that
I personally kind of lost
it and ended up in tears.
Because we didn't
have soundtracks.
It's not London
or San Francisco,
but 300 people broke out in the
most beautiful African freedom
songs as we left this field
and marched onto the streets.
And it was truly a moment of
absolute personal liberation,
I think, for so many people.
You could see the people
were literally kind of dizzy
with excitement and joy.
And so it was a really,
really special moment.
It happened absolutely
without any incident.
There was no violence, either
verbal or physical whatsoever.
We were able to come
back into the field.
There was then a
festival, and we
were even able to run a party
in a private venue that evening.
Again, some security
threats came through,
but it all went off
without a hitch.
And going back to my
previous point, when
we talked to our
partners and when
we talked to some of the people
who were participating in this,
there was an enormous
sense of just being boosted
by a massive battery of
power, that people finally
felt powerful.
They felt they had agency.
And we believe that the
ramifications of this
will go way beyond
Swaziland, that it
will go across the continent.
Because it really was a
moment of significant success
for an LGBT movement in
a hostile environment.
So the same weekend, Istanbul
Pride was due to take place.
And my colleague, Uri, was
there to stand shoulder
to shoulder with our
partners in Turkey.
We've worked with them
for the last three years
around pride to
raise visibility.
We've run thunderclaps.
We've run petitions to ensure
that the world is watching.
Unfortunately, the same pattern
has happened for the last two
or three years.
It happened again.
And I was telling Alex,
just as a side story--
because we're in a tech company,
I think this is interesting.
I was in a hotel in Swaziland.
I happened to have a pretty
decent internet connection.
And there were lots of
Facebook Lives coming
from Pride in Istanbul as
things started to become
difficult and violent.
And I was actually able to
see my colleague on some
of those Facebook Lives.
And was literally,
with WhatsApp,
able to direct him out of
danger, as the police started
to engage, which I
found very, very surreal
and a real indicator, I guess,
of the power of technology.
But to continue with the
story of Istanbul Pride,
as I'm sure you all
know, Istanbul Pride
is an organization that applies
for permission every year
to run the pride
parade in Istanbul.
They neither receive approval
nor denial each year,
so they go ahead
and do it anyway.
And what usually happens is that
around 12 hours before they're
due to start,
there is a ban that
is announced, which
is particularly cruel,
because it just doesn't
allow any planning,
or any contingency planning.
In terms of negotiations
with the police,
it was agreed that
a statement could
be read out in four
places around the city
by LGBT activists.
That happened, but
very, very soon after--
literally minutes after--
the police, with dogs,
started to mobilize
around those four points
and gave people very, very
little time to disperse,
and eventually engaged.
And they used a lot of bullets.
They used tear gas.
They used dogs against
people who were completely
peacefully claiming their
right to freedom of assembly.
There was no registered
crime committed by anybody,
but people were viciously
attacked by the police
and by dogs.
We had a lawyer on
call, who's also
an activist, ready to help
out if my colleague, Uri, were
arrested during that time.
And he was simultaneously
beaten by 10 police officers
and attacked by a
dog, and had sustained
very significant injuries to
his left leg during that attack.
And so Istanbul is a
moment to pause for us,
a moment of reflection on
how far we still have to go.
It was a massive contrast to the
joy and liberation and agency
we saw in Swaziland.
We're not giving up.
We will continue to stand side
by side with Istanbul Pride.
We're already talking
to them and working
with them on, perhaps,
smarter strategies
next year to enable
this to happen
in a way that won't
lead to people being
hurt in such brutal manner.
SPEAKER: Wow.
Quite a contrast.
Could you talk a little about
All Out's role in those prides?
Because obviously,
as you said, you're
not organizing the pride.
There are local organizers who
are leading on these projects.
But what does All
Out actually do?
MATT BEARD: Yeah, so for
Swaziland, we, effectively,
through our membership around
the world, we funded it.
So we enabled that to
happen through funding.
So we ran a round about four
or five months ahead of time.
We ran a crowdfunding
campaign that
went out via email and social
media to our global membership.
It told the story of a number of
LGBTQ individuals in Swaziland,
their personal journeys, and
how important pride would
be to them.
And we asked our members
to make small donations.
As I said, the average
gift around $19
to enable that to happen.
Our appeals kind
of happen quickly.
So when the email
goes out, there's
a series of three emails.
It's over within a week.
We know whether we've
reached the target.
We reached the target and we
were able to remit those funds.
And then we worked
with them kind
of as a friendly critical voice.
We are really, really
very, very strict
on the idea that we don't
run these events, that we
give agency to
our local partners
to run them as they see fit.
But we've also started to
collect some experience of how
pride happens in different
hostile environments
around the world.
And so our role is also
to provide some advice
when is wanted and needed.
In Istanbul, our role was
really as a long-term partner
to stand in solidarity.
So we did lots of
media work around it.
We wanted to raise the
visibility of the issues that
were being faced there.
We provided this live
reporting service
from the ground-- which social
media very much offers--
with Uri providing a live
feed to our supporters,
and then following
up with lots of media
work afterwards to really draw
attention to the human rights
violations that took place.
SPEAKER: Cool.
So do folks in the room have
questions about pride events
around the world or protests?
I'll pass you the microphone.
For the LiveStream.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Yeah, thank you for your work.
It sounds like
you're doing really
courageous, difficult,
complicated stuff.
It's amazing and very inspiring.
My question has to do
with colonialism and how
you think about All Out's role
with respect to colonialism--
spreading ideas or ideologies.
And especially in
Swaziland, Christianity
was obviously deposited
there colonially, right?
So I guess what
I'm actually trying
to understand is
how do you think
about the anti-LGBT forces that
exist in places like Swaziland
and Istanbul?
How do you model
them in your mind?
How do you think about
where they're operating from
or their reasons?
And how would you summarize
your goal with respect
to those forces?
Because I understand the
humanitarian goal of you
know you want LGBT people
to be free, and I 100%
understand [INAUDIBLE] is that.
I just want to
understand the other part
for the political aspect.
MATT BEARD: Thanks.
It's a great question, because
in terms of the work we do,
and in terms of the fact
that All Out is registered
in New York and
the United States,
and the United States is
a global superpower that
has been accused of all
sorts of neocolonialism,
and that I'm the [INAUDIBLE]
direction, I come from Britain.
That also has that
experience 100 years earlier.
We have to be really careful
about that narrative.
And so I think your
question is a great one.
I'll come to the meat of
the question in a moment.
One of the things
I want to mention
is we try and work on a
communications narrative
that makes clear that,
particularly, in terms
of British colonialism,
that it is actually
homophobia that is the
export, not homosexuality.
So there are 52 commonwealth
countries in the world.
37% of those,
shockingly, are still
countries where it
is illegal to be gay.
And most of those 37 countries,
even more shockingly,
still have 19th century
British colonial legislation
that talks about
carnal knowledge
against the order of
nature, and criminalizes
the act of, basically,
penetrative male gay sex.
So we work on our
communications narrative
that tries to flip that around.
Because in many countries
around the world,
there is an internal
homophobic narrative
that says homosexuality
has come from the West.
It's come from Europe.
It's come from America.
And we have to protect
"African" or "Caribbean"
or "Latin American"
or "Asian" values
against this gay invasion.
And what we've been
able to do, partially--
it's a very big and long
job, it's a bumpy road--
but is to kind of
invert that narrative.
So for example, when the
Commonwealth heads of state
came to London for their summit
just a couple of months ago,
we projected onto the
side of the UK parliament,
making clear that
in 37 countries
of the 52 in the Commonwealth,
it is illegal to be gay.
and We were calling
on the UK government
to apologize to the millions
of citizens of the Commonwealth
for that legacy of
British colonial law.
But in terms of the second part
of your question of where that
comes from, where that
homophobia is rooted,
and how we deal with
it politically--
and I think it has to be
named, but it is often--
religion is often
used or utilized
or exploited by
powerful elites in order
to secure their positions.
So again, our
counter-strategy is really
to attempt to work
with progressive faith
as much as we can,
because we believe
it's one of the most important
ways to unlock that narrative.
So just to give you another
example of a concrete campaign
that we've been working on
over the last few weeks,
there is a self-declared
female imam in Berlin
who has established a mosque,
where men and women can come
together to pray together,
where LGBTQ people are welcome,
where Jews, Christians,
atheists are welcome.
It's an engagement space.
And we have helped
her set this up.
We've helped to set up a
community and engagement center
that brings people together.
And we really believe
that by unlocking
some of those closed
doors of religion,
that is one way
to work with this.
And then the other way that
we deal with this, I think,
is to do what I've been talking
about a little bit already,
is to really ensure that--
All Out sometimes
very much takes
a back seat, that
it's our partners that
are very much in
the frontline, who
are being seen in the media.
And we very much
create a narrative
that these are home
grown, as they are.
It's not a narrative.
It's reality.
These are homegrown
movements, people working
for their own liberation.
SPEAKER: Great.
Other folks in the room?
You can just pass it right on.
AUDIENCE: Very impressed.
I took some notes.
I like some of the terms you
use, like invert narrative,
unlock narrative.
I grew up in the Bible
Belt, West Virginia.
There's awful lot of
good people there.
I think it's really
important to address
the goodness in Christianity.
MATT BEARD: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: And to never
use the word Christianity
without qualifying, somehow,
in a follow-up statement,
or something.
Because what's happening
is all this divisiveness
is causing Christianity to be
pitted against homosexuality.
It's not true.
If you actually read the Bible
or study what Martin Luther
King stood for, who was a
real Christian, what I think
is effective, in my opinion,
is confronting people
with their own
beliefs, which I think
is similar to what you said
about unlocking the narrative.
So when I saw those happy faces
and the African freedom songs,
I thought that was beautiful.
So I just wonder if you could
talk a little bit about what
is effective besides--
for instance, let me give you
an example of what I think
is not effective.
One is my emotional immaturity
myself, getting angry
at my relatives, as I have.
Kaepernick, the guy-- I'm sure
I mispronounced his name--
the football player who got the
Amnesty International's highest
award.
I thought he was
ineffective, because you
can't take the anthem
protest very far without them
making it irrelevant to
what you're trying to say.
I thought it was great
amnesty gave him an award,
but in the '60s, they
thought these things out,
like what's going to work.
So could you talk about
what's going to work?
MATT BEARD: Sure.
I'll preface it by
saying that I think
your own emotional authenticity
and integrity, I think,
should play a part
in the struggle.
I think righteous anger at
the way LGBTQ people have
been treated for millennia
is part of the equation.
I really do.
Frankly, I think straight
people should be very grateful
that when we celebrate what
happened in Christopher
Street in 1969 through
pride, we do so
in a spirit of joy and
celebration and not anger
and revenge because we've
been treated really badly.
So I do think it's part of
the equation, but only a part.
What I think works
is a combination
of different theories of
change coming together.
So I'll be really honest.
All Out doesn't provide the full
spectrum of change ingredients.
And the way I always talk about
this, it's like baking a cake.
So to bake a cake,
you need the butter.
You need the flour.
You need the eggs.
You need the milk.
What All Out does is provide
people power to change.
We bring together those
millions of ordinary voices.
And together, those
voices raised the volume.
They change hearts and minds.
They change the conversation.
And we believe passionately
in that theory of change.
We call it new power.
Our founder, Jeremy Heimans,
has a book out right now called
"New Power."
And it's about
peer-driven, participatory,
nonhierarchical change models.
But, or and, we also
believe that that is not
sufficient on its own.
So our friends at HRC, who are
working on high-level advocacy
in the corridors of power--
I mean, we have fewer friends
in the corridor of power
than we used to, but that is
also incredibly important work.
Our colleagues at Human Rights
Watch and Amnesty International
who are documenting human
rights violations, that is also
incredibly important work.
Friends in the legal
profession, who
are supporting strategic
litigation to challenge
criminalisation of
homosexuality, that is also
incredibly important work.
So my personal
belief, really, is
that it is the combination
that is effective,
that all of those different
theories of change
are greater than the
sum of the parts.
And when we can work effectively
together, it creates change.
And I would actually take
that one step further--
and I know this is very kind of
vogue-ish to say in the United
States right now because of
the current environment that
we're in--
but I think if you can make
it also intersectional,
then it's even stronger.
So we've been really trying to
work with the gender justice
movement, with the racial
justice movement here
and in the UK and in
the rest of Europe
to kind of form
intersectional alliances.
Because so often, particularly
with gender justice,
our enemies are actually
the same people.
And so I think its
really important
that we work together.
SPEAKER: Any more folks?
We can touch on a
couple of other things.
I think we would be remiss
if we had you on Google
and we didn't talk a little
bit about digital strategies.
That is, really, the
core of what you do.
MATT BEARD: Absolutely.
SPEAKER: And so we see a lot
of this, what is sometimes
called, slacktivism,
right or I think
you called it keyboard activism
one time in a conversation.
And there's this
questioning, does it actually
accomplish anything?
Can I, sitting in my room
at home on the internet,
actually make an impact
elsewhere in the world?
And obviously, All Out
believes that you can, right?
So I'm curious about how
you think about that,
and what kinds of things
people can do that are helpful,
what's less helpful, and how
we should think about that.
MATT BEARD: Yeah,
so we passionately
believe that you can.
We passionately
believe that you don't
have to give blood, sweat,
and tears to be an activist.
Obviously, if you
can, that's awesome,
but not everybody
can or wants to.
And there are ways
in which people
can use the power of virtual
activism, keyboard activism,
slacktivism, whatever
you want to call it,
to make a difference.
And the way that that
difference happens
is through a multiplier effect.
So me taking a digital
action on my own
isn't really going
to change the world.
But when I join my
voice with thousands,
hundreds of thousands, sometimes
millions of other people
who are doing the same
thing at the same time
and creating a moment
of energy, that does,
actually, really create change.
It creates change in
two ways, two main ways.
I think, firstly,
as I've mentioned
before, it can kind of
change the conversation
or change the narrative.
Sometimes we literally have
got hundreds of thousands
of people taking
action and talking
about a particular campaign that
we're running at the same time.
And whether we actually achieve
the final outcome or not,
that has actually moved
that conversation forward.
It has challenged the
counter-narrative, that
LGBT plus people off unable
to look after children,
shouldn't be getting
married, spreading disease.
Whatever that
counter-narrative is,
it enables it to be challenged.
And then on some
of our campaigns,
we know that we have actually
achieved a concrete outcome.
We try very hard
not to be greedy
with attribution, because
of the cake metaphor
that I was talking
about earlier.
Because sometimes
it's very difficult
to know whether it
was the meeting HLC
had with someone in government
or the public campaign
that All Out did.
But we know that we do
achieve concrete outcomes.
I'll give you one
example where we
know for sure because the
decision-makers told us.
So there probably are
people in this audience
for whom the name Steven
Anderson will ring a bell.
Steven Anderson is
the Arizona pastor
who celebrated the deaths of
49 of our brothers and sisters
at the Pulse nightclub
in Orlando in his church.
And pastor Anderson was planning
a speaking tour in South Africa
to spread that
message of hatred,
so we ran a global petition.
We collected a dossier
of evidence against him,
and we presented that
to the interior ministry
of South Africa.
As some of you may know,
South Africa's constitution
is actually the most
pro-LGBT in the world.
It has very significant
provisions around hate speech,
and they responded positively
and denied him an entry visa.
He got stuck at JFK.
He couldn't travel.
He was not able to spread
that message of hatred.
And they came back
to us directly
to tell us that it was a
result of that people power,
of that mass international
community coming together
to draw attention to this
man's hate speech that
led to the decision to deny
him that entry visa into South
Africa.
He then tried to change his
travel plans to go to Botswana.
We didn't run a
campaign in Botswana,
but the Botswana government just
followed the South African lead
and then also denied him
an entry visa to travel.
SPEAKER: That's a great example.
And you also do I think a lot of
grassroots fundraising, right?
MATT BEARD: Correct.
SPEAKER: Can you
talk about how that
works, sort of practically?
MATT BEARD: Yeah.
When I came into
the organization
2 and 1/2 years ago, it seemed
a bit counter-intuitive to me
that we had a database
of hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of global citizens
who, by definition, wanted
to stand up for
LGBT plus people,
but that we weren't
asking them for money
for our frontline partners,
like in Swaziland.
So in 2016, we tested a couple
of crowdfunding appeals,
and they have the brand
name Grassroots Giving.
And it kind-- we were
kind of surprised at just
how great the response was.
People really wanted to feel
that they were contributing
directly to a tangible piece
of frontline service delivery,
or activism.
So in 2016, we tested
this by running an appeal
to keep a shelter for homeless
LGBT youth open in Poland,
and we were able to keep that
open right through the winter
months so that the kids
who were in this place
weren't thrown out into a very
cold climate, but also a very
homophobic climate.
And then we also ran a
crowdfunder for Uganda Pride
in 2016.
Both those reached the target,
so in 2017, we rolled this out.
We now run one
every single month.
The defining moment, I
guess, for this program
for us came in 2017 during
the Chechnya crisis.
And for those who
are in the room
or on the call who don't
know what happened there,
in 2017 in Chechnya, the
state security forces
started to illegally
kidnap and round up
men presumed to be gay or bi.
They were taken to
illegal detention centers
outside the city of Grozny.
They were tortured and, in
some cases, were murdered.
It was the most
significant moment
of state-sponsored
persecution of LGBT
plus people since the Nazis.
We had been a longtime partner
of the LGBT Russian LGBT
network, which was
organizing evacuations
of men who had either
survived the camps
or who were at risk
of going into them.
And we said to them,
this is something
we should run through our
Grassroots Giving program.
And we thought we could raise--
the sums we raised were modest.
So we thought we
could raise $20,000.
That would have
paid for, perhaps,
six or seven evacuations.
We hit Send on the email,
and within 23 minutes,
we had reached that target.
And we ended up
raising $250,000, which
for an organization
like All Out,
is a very large amount of money.
And that came from over
120 different countries.
It was a massive act
of global solidarity.
And in those very,
very dark days,
it was some form of
redemption, that there
was this generosity around
the world and a willingness
to stand up to that.
We also ran an absolutely
enormous petition,
working with avowals.
1.2 million people
signed our petition.
Uri, my colleague, who I was
talking about earlier who
went to Istanbul, went to
Moscow to deliver that petition.
And he and our activist
partners were arrested in Moscow
and were never able to
deliver that petition.
We ended up having
to do it digitally,
and I'm sure it went
straight into the trash can.
But that moment was very,
very special for us.
So we continue to do
one of these appeals
every single month.
Right now, we're raising
money for the mosque in Berlin
that I talked about earlier.
But we've also ran appeals
for safe houses for people
fleeing from ISIS.
We funded helplines for
survivors of anti-LGBT hate
crime community centers.
A beautiful project
in Kurdistan in Iraq
to paint pro-LGBT murals
on public streets.
So we continue to work with
our global network of partners
to see where there are
these projects that
require these relatively
modest, but sometimes very
transformational,
injection of funds
in order to make a difference.
And we believe this is
another kind of form
of catalyzing, catalyzing
movements, fueling
movements around the world.
SPEAKER: Great.
Well, Matt, I want to thank
you so much for coming in today
and chatting with us.
And thanks for coming.
MATT BEARD: Thank you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]